check our sponsors and nature's blends
they specialize in premium Ethiopian
black seed products you can also use the
discount code Salam 10 for 10% of their
products so this trip is my first time
thank you brother thank you for this
trip it's my first time
Kalea i buy the nav astra for and
who see him olia a buddy and Athena
Astra for
for see him la tapa not my mess in LA
la da Cunha tomograph mess in LA
in La Jolla Felix little baby in a long
leg feeling good over Jimmy in a
wonderful reply
in allahu dhu Virginia kulu kulu Bishop
last video who led a burrito butter and
a body he wear for a neesee
Atena whistling where fool
NEC
at local ugly on mobile where for NEC
hello Kandhar river where fool any see
you man
Oh
so anything guys
and I just saw a video of a con in Umrah
and I just wanna share Amanda with you
guys tell you that sort of video so
panel oh you know sometimes you know we
look at somebody who's coming in a sin
you know and always it's important to
advise those who are committing the sin
however what happens a lot of the times
is that what people do is that they
start judging and what the judging by
the act like they are saved so basically
they look at their current position so
they look at the composition become
practicing this guy isn't this guy
sinning I'm not I'm doing this but
they're not or whatever it may be
something might not feel about this
figure why is he doing now why is doing
that yeah now icon is a ombres now akin
could be someone that's going to change
for the better now where are you going
to be do you know where your future is
gonna be if anybody acknowledges that
they don't know where they're gonna be
that they may a lot like they might be
misguided so if you have that mentality
you never ever even if you advise him
you will never ever have an attitude of
arrogance because if you look at shaitan
and adam alayhis-salam
Shaitaan was a worshipper of Allah
everywhere very righteous right very
righteous worship of allah subhanho wa
taala but it wasn't his current
situation but it was what was his end
very important provinces for us to not
ever look down on anybody in any way
shape or form you see videos of me who
have advised many people and I'm hoping
to advise myself but advising these
people does not mean that I think I'm
better than them if that was the case or
if I ever fought like that
what a shame on me if I did however this
doesn't stop me from advising people in
the future and it shouldn't stop anyone
from advising me I'm just advising
because Allah says in the Quran Allah
terrorizes you a group of people who
would enjoin good and forbid evil and we
have to this is what mace is religion
beautiful and I for sure that remind
them of you and I'm happy to see a con
in Umrah insha'Allah doing that and we
hope a lot changes him for the better
and changes me for the
and changes you guys for the better
inshallah because we all need
improvement and you never know that he
might change his ways completely or he
already has probably and he repents and
those who were looking down on him are
going to become worse than him
we also lost the panelist Allah to guide
us and I for sure this beautiful video
of you guys inshallah it was amazing it
was hard touch inshallah may Allah
accept it from him and accept it from us
assalamualaikum warahmatullah better yet